of course you're in the 45th season
right but this is your 23rd year is that
correct right because we do two seasons
a year it was a very big show with my
family we watch it with the kids when
they were growing up and then my son got
older and he went off to college and he
kind of stopped watching the show for a
while and then he came back to it which
was amazing I love that college is the
area where we will tend to lose people
because they go and they have their own
life and then they often come back but
what really has helped Survivor
become a family show is about 12 or so
years ago we really made a concerted
effort especially me the thing I'm
constantly driving with our teams is
imagine a seven-year-old watching this
show and dreaming of doing it and it's
not because we're trying to attract an
audience that's part of it but really in
my soul I know it's in all of us there's
something that Survivor touches and you
see it when you watch just one episode
this idea of being taken out of your
Ordinary World and dropped in the middle
of a real jungle with a bunch of
strangers and two things are happening
you have to rely on each other to
survive and you're simultaneously
conspiring against each other to get rid
of people it's a simple little format
but if you execute it well it works I
want to talk to you about celebrity fans
of the show because you talk about how
it's a winner take all show but in a lot
of ways it really isn't anymore because
people like Sia just seem to like what
they like and throw money at somebody
that people love so how did that all
come about Sia has given to date next
season if she continues with her see a
prize she will break a million dollars
in personal money that she has given to
players over the years and how it
started was
we were friends and she loved Survivor
and that's how we originally met and so
she was coming to some of the live shows
and she came to a live finale back when
we had it and there was a guy Ty and he
was just a very lovely human and he was
a big animal activist and we're doing
the live show we're in the middle of a
live show
and I hear this voice say Jeff
I see see an inner wig and she's walking
up to the stage and she says I I just
love you and I want to give you some
money and that's where it started curb
thought is this I make a lot of money
I've been really lucky and I want to
share it with the people who entertain
me and bring me joy and one of those
shows is Survivor like our last season I
wake up at like 7 45 the day after the
finale aired and she is calling me for
like the ninth time and I finally wake
up and pick it up and she goes I'm ready
to give away money can we get him on the
phone that's how fast it happens and
then your producer brain Clicks in which
is I don't want her to change her mind
she's going to give money to these
people so you just start calling and
then she tells them and they cry and
they can't believe their biggest fan and
you know last year we had a guy that
that Carson that got some money from her
and he told her he goes I am your number
one fan I listen to every single thing
you've ever done so there's this really
cool connection but that's all Sia
foreign